maybe I flash it up and go with this oh
come on
sure NBA Finals party I need to sign off
on the guest list
I left the guest list to you I said keep
it sophisticated done good you bite the
kid you said keep it sophisticated why
do you hate fun you really want me to
invite the kid if I might think here
that I got to babysit I like the kid I
want you to invite the kid can I please
shave us off no you may not because your
team lost therefore you have to look
like me indefinitely which one go for
third option get out
Friday run a final check on the party
list question Captain Steve Rogers too
soon sending invite no way I'm gonna
watch the NBA Finals with mr. stork so
you're gonna let me go ha nice try buddy
[Music]
perfect timing I need to go downtown and
get me snacks for Tim Duncan happy -
game starting here faster than delivery
with the whole thing now remember it's
for Tim Duncan so nothing fancy just the
fundamentals come on let's go I'm
expecting change
these guys are really here without my
night just want to watch the game I
think I know that guy
hey happy kid where are you mr. stork
madam out there devastated
where are the crackers I'm getting them
right now is there anyone Wow your DJ
get rid you spider-man what are you
doing here I'm going to this violence
parties darks party I'm going to
well can we get a picture extra low flow
coming thank you Wow me that deaf we are
first another one another another one I
got to go out of my skin keep the change
can't believe I'm watching the science
of this is doctor
[Music]
[Applause]
MJ MJ called me magic is social Tim
Duncan he's right over there
[Music]
Morgan did you see you work wanted to
watch the game
[Applause]
got my change these are great you one
time thanks hey everybody I think I know
that guy they're stickin Stanley and
even more trailers I was actually
waiting for them to drop all this to do
a video about it I love it they use this
whole special ad to haze the new guy
it's all about making spider-man run
around in circles to get off-brand
crackers we'll talk about that in a
second there's so many unintentionally
funny things about this but they're very
open about it because it's basically
done as an ad for the movie so it's just
another example of them stuffing Stanley
into the trailer the same way that
Deadpool to did it which I am totally
all for it is advanced age you want to
use them as much as possible because if
you wait you might not get the
opportunity Wow nice suit definite
Stanley in the history of Marvel he is
the ultimate hype man and there is that
Spider Man giveaway that's still going
on now too for the action figures all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so if you're not a big sports person you
have no idea what's going on the NBA
Finals are happening right now they
haven't had the final game yet LeBron is
a treasure but they were doing a
spider-man ad for the movie coinciding
with the NBA Finals so it's meant to be
a funny trailer that promotes the movie
and promotes the final so like they just
want spider-man to be really excited
about watching the game so that people
will get really excited about watching
the game and hopefully get excited about
watching the movie but they're using the
whole thing to sort of poke fun at Tom
Hollands version of spider-man like the
fact that happy picking his nose as he
gets off the elevator tells him to go
get some snacks for Tim Duncan who's
sitting here he's just a basketball star
if you're not a basketball person
obviously you know who Magic Johnson is
you probably know who DJ call it is so
they're just trying to hit all the bases
here they're trying to get the sports
people they're trying to get the people
who don't watch sports but like Stanley
and like spider-man and like Tony Stark
dumping on spider-man what oh he said he
wanted to watch the game I love the way
Tony just gives in the middle finger
from courtside genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist this whole
trailer just a parody of other trailers
which i think is actually a better
version of a trailer like people get
really upset when they think they're
being spa
build on stuff this is an easy way
around that problem where they did the
same thing for Captain America Civil War
but they just had them just go at each
other in really funny ways that had
absolutely nothing to do with the movie
but sort of gave you the idea for what
the tone of the film was going to be
what the dynamic was so there's also
kind of what's going on with spider-man
homecoming we're happy calls him where
are you at Oh mr. stark mad that I'm not
there
oh he's devastated absolutely devastated
when in fact he actually knew that
Ironman had already gone to the game and
was sitting courtside but even more than
the spider-man stuff in this I just
loved Jon Favreau being on set with
Robert Downey jr. there was a little bit
in that behind the scenes that I posted
last week where he was talking about how
it felt a lot like making the original
Iron Man movie like that inaugural crew
when Marvel was still making that big
bet they were still financing their
movies with Merrill Lynch with like a
big loan so they didn't know how it was
going to pay off and if the movie had
failed
if Ironman had not done well they had
leveraged all their characters so Marvel
would have lost everything so if you
think it's bad that they don't have the
rights to x-men they would have lost all
these other core characters and they
would have been owned by a bank that the
bank would have then leased to the other
Studios to make really bad superhero
films so I don't think they were ever in
any danger but they definitely dodged an
Ultron sighs vibranium bullet but
what'll happen is because we're within
the four week window now there might be
like one more big trailer and then
they'll drop a little bit more footage
there'll be TV spots so there will be
more stuff for the movie but you'll
start seeing more funny trailers like
this they would probably use more
Stanley if they could but he actually
charges a ton of money he doesn't do
these for free like this is an ad so
everybody that appears in this is
getting paid for a DJ Khalid got paid
the random hot girls that they stuff in
here they got paid a ton of money to Tim
Duncan got a truckload of money I mean
if you're a big NBA star you might do a
walk-on cameo in a movie for free but if
you're gonna do a big Sony ad you're
going to get paid big-time and that
actually reminds me funny thing about
the trailer here is he's getting off
obviously he says Oh MJ in its Magic
Johnson also got paid a ton of money to
appear in this but let me know what you
guys think about then doing ads like
this versus traditional trailer
like you do want to see a trailer you
actually want to see what's going on
with the movie but I'm totally cool with
them doing funny stuff like this in fact
this would actually probably better
because there'd be fewer people
complaining about movie plot being
spoiled or potentially being spoiled I
still feel like there's a lot of Secrets
they haven't revealed like they ended
their special with them saying that and
then a shot of Captain America so all of
a sudden conspiracy theories start to
rise in the comments we just saw the
Black Panther trailer that's really
where I'm expecting to see Captain
America but speaking of MJ a lot of
you've asked me about the Zende of rumor
so there's a rumor about her character's
identity people wonder last year if she
was secretly going to be a version of
Mary Jane we actually found out who she
is
so let me know in the comments if you
want me to do a video about that
but I do have more black panther that
I've planned for next week I'll be
talking about his powers his abilities
the way Marvel is explaining how he gets
his super-strength with the heart-shaped
herb it's actually pretty practical they
explain quite a bit they even said that
Ulysses Klaw is going to get his comic
book arm because he still has that one
arm in the trailer so that'll all happen
next week but there's new Game of
Thrones coming later tonight I have some
episode 1 photos that I'll break down so
we'll say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Drake man please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here to
rewatch that black panther trailer and
you can click here to learn all about
his suit afraid that's right he has a
new food in the movie thank you so much
for watching
high five I'll see you guys tonight